colloquially colloquially colloquially
colloquially colloquial you know what
I'm talking about
the police Lord let this girl eat more
than her mother hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we're going to be reviewing and
actually following supermodel Bella
hadid's diet with some Abbey twists of
course but first let me tell you what my
sponsor ritual now I know a lot of you
are actively trying to conceive are
already pregnant or are recently
postpartum and looking to maintain your
health during this new phase of life I
know the supplement world is really
really overwhelming but I personally
really loved rituals prenatal because
it's third party tested and they're
really intentional and transparent about
the ingredients they use and why a lot
of moms can also find a lot of prenatals
can be hard on the stomach especially
when maybe they're already struggling
with morning sickness but ritual has a
unique delay release design to bypass
the stomach and dissolve in the
intestine to maximize nutrient
absorption so you can even take ritual
on an empty stomach without exacerbating
morning sex it also has a unique capsule
in capsule design that allows them to
effectively combine omega-3 DHA with all
of the other high quality nutrients like
vitamin D3 in two little capsules I also
love that ritual is very cognizant of
their environmental impact so they use
100 recycled materials in their
packaging and their mailers are made
with recycled newsprints and plant
fibers their multivitamin is also vegan
gluten free and allergen free with no
colorants added sugars additives or
unlisted ingredients and for my
non-pregnant friends they also have a
regular multivitamin for men and women
A50 plus option a postnatal option and
one specifically for teens but it's
super convenient because they just
deliver it right to your door as part of
a subscription so even when you're
having super mom brain you won't run out
so if you're looking to conceive or you
just want to fill in some of those
potential nutritional gaps with a high
quality multivitamin you can use my
promo code and check out the link in the
description to get 20 off of your first
three months of ritual and of course a
quick disclaimer that this diet was
compiled from multiple secondary sources
where Bella herself was quoted so I
really can't speak to the legitimacy or
the accuracy of her day-to-day diet
based on these sources I also don't know
if all of these meals would be pieced
together in a single day but it also
really doesn't matter because I will
simply be using Bella's alleged meals as
a template for teaching a gentle
nutrition and that means the meals that
you see me eat are also not meant to
serve as a suggestion for how you should
eat so always speak to a registered
dietitian about your unique needs
alright folks let's dive into the
celebrity diet news so according to some
various scientific sources sarcasm noted
Bella doesn't believe in diets which is
both refreshing and a little shocking
considering that her mom Yolanda has
basically built herself a real peachy
reputation for pushing Uber restrictive
diets on both of her young girls so
their bodies are big and bulky and I
mean they eat like like man pretty much
all the food that we're eating is like a
heart attack in a meal you can have one
one night of being bad right I was
actually really good this week and then
you got to get back in your diet though
and it's hard to not eat any sugar and
it's hard to have to eat salad every day
a little bit now that's to be the half
of that Gigi's in charge of her own diet
but to be on your best weight
maybe this is an act of rebellion
against her mom's restriction or maybe
she just inherently respects her body
and appreciates good food either way we
love to see it having said that while
she may have been able to reject her
mom's disordered relationship with food
she's still not immune to diet culture
especially as a model in the public eye
Bella's nutritionist Dr Charles passler
who's a chiropractor by the way not a
medical doctor FYI has been quoted as
recommending Bella follow a lower carb
high protein diet to keep her fit and
lean and that little nugget of diet
inside feels a little at odds with
Bella's alleged no diet Mantra since
manipulating your diet to stay lean is
by definition a diet so I'm kind of
having mixed feelings about this day
already but you know your girl is going
to be making adjustments as I see fit so
let's go attempt to eat like a
supermodel today well kind of maybe
we'll see okay so according to Vogue
magazine Bella works out for a solid two
hours every day and I mean if this
amount of activity feels good to Bella
and it supports her Fitness and energy
levels great like you do you but for
most of us non-model folks lots of Hard
pass most authorities recommend 30 to 60
Minutes of physical activity five days a
week to really optimize health benefits
so don't feel like you're slacking if
clocking a solid 14-hour training week
is not your journey this is a reminder
to always listen to your body and what
it needs most even if that means like a
20 minute workout taking a rest day or a
gentle walk or stretch because most of
us have way too much on our to-do lists
for a two hour daily sweat slash papay
she's licking her chop so I don't know
about that so apparently Bella's routine
consists of 20 minutes of running uh
followed by a boxing session followed by
some strength training exercises that
Target the ABS and the glutes with 10
minutes of stretching before and after
um
it's a no for me yeah girl doesn't run
hashtag postpartum pelvic floor and I
also don't have boxing gloves and I also
don't have two hours to kill in the gym
so I'm gonna do a quick walk do some ab
exercises on the floor there maybe some
glute work and stretch a little and call
it a day
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that'll do okay so according to Vogue
here her post-workout recovery meal is
usually a smoothie a juice or a protein
drink that she has 30 minutes after a
training session where she says she
tries to prioritize protein to
strengthen muscle mass and increase the
effects of the session let's talk about
it of course protein is important
post-workout but carbs are also
essential for replenishing glycogen
stores and eliciting a little insulin
response to dry protein into the muscle
faster also the anabolic window for
post-workout recovery fuel is actually
much wider than we once thought most
people don't need to rush home to chug a
protein shake within like 30 minutes we
actually have about four hours around
the training session to really optimize
protein muscle synthesis though how long
you could push it will also depend on
your pre-workout nutrition as well so if
Bella had had some protein like two
hours before her workout she would have
a lot more flexibility in terms of when
to get that post-workout fuel in but
since this
since this first meal of the day I'm
glad to see she's prioritizing it pretty
soon after training so I'm not sure how
she would manage to work out for two
hours on empty because your girl was
hungry as I'm gonna go with the Smoothie
root because the juice would be great as
like a pre-workout for like a quick
burst of energy but it's not going to
give us the protein that we want and a
protein drink I mean I don't know what
that means maybe it's just like protein
powder in water that's not going to give
us the carbs that we want so I'm going
to combine The Best of Both Worlds and
since we've got breakfast coming when
I'm gonna have like a more satiating
balanced meal I'm gonna keep this super
easy lower fat so it's easier for me to
digest fast and just stick to some fruit
for carbs and some protein powder for a
protein the banana
Frozen cherries
I need a fancy straw we're gonna go with
my
kids smoothie cup
which I guess I'm gonna have to refill
that three times
but it'll be worth it
let's look at that
hmm
hmm
that is so good
all right post workout down let's talk
breakfast
um it is unclear whether or not she has
the breakfast in addition to the
post-workout but I really hope so
because your girl is hungry so that's
how we're gonna do it so according to
Harper's Bazaar Bella's go-to breakfast
is either eggs and sausage or an egg
sandwich on a bagel from her favorite
New York City bagel shop and do not make
fun of me for how I say bagel I am
Canadian and I have my own way of
pronouncing it
um but you know in New York bagels are
pretty much like their own food group so
it sounds good to me oh hi me again just
FYI despite what dye culture will tell
you a bagel is not equivalent to six
slices of bread it's actually closer to
like three slices of bread or around a
cup of rice and most research recommends
like 1.1 to 1.5 grams of carbs per
kilogram of body weight after a high
intensity workout so for Bella that
would be around like 60 to 80 grams of
carbs like likely in the higher end of
this range because she did work out for
two hours so yeah can we just stop
demonizing Bagels I love me some
breakfast sausage don't get me wrong but
I'm gonna do the egg bagel sandwich root
because that way we're getting that
protein in the eggs and some carbs in
the bagel and I'm gonna bump it up make
it more of a satiating balanced hunger
crushing combo and I'm gonna show you
how let's do it let's scramble some eggs
all right I usually do like a combo or
like a little bit of olive oil just to
like coat the pan and also so the butter
doesn't burn but I like the flavor of
butter better so I do a little BOCES
just like to coat that it's probably
good I always have a tendency to add way
too much butter and then I basically
just like fry everything deep fry it so
I'm going to leave that butter on the
side in case I need to add more
um okay eggs
it's probably good plus the protein
shake
I'm not starving
a little a whiskey
[Applause]
and pep
foreign
and I'm gonna add cheese because I like
everything better when there's cheese on
it
I don't know if Bella likes cheese
but I don't care because I do
so
we'll just do a quick little scramble
because it's going to go oh I should
start toasting
on a bagel these are not Montreal bagels
and I'll tell you why I prefer a
Montreal style Bagel or I guess New York
style I know they're different but I
don't know the difference because I'm
Canadian and we Montreal style Bagels
but anyways I love a good Montreal style
bagel
but my kids don't like them they're just
too uh chewy for them they're hard to
eat so I had to go with the basic Bagels
that my my actual kids would eat because
I don't like to waste food in the past
no we don't okay I think these are like
pre-split perfs
there we go
all right let's toast
toast kind of like a little baby
omelette
thing with the cheese oozing out
um
[Music]
just give it a nice pat down
I don't think you're supposed to Pat
your eggs
but
here we are all right
I got some lettuce
I'll just give a quick rinse rinse
we're gonna add some extra fiber here a
little bit more toast a little bit more
toasting are you a double toaster or a
single toaster I like it with a little
more color a little more texture
especially when we got something fluffy
in the middle like some scrambled eggs
it's got some Aroma tomato here
Buttes and those are our sad little
butter pad that just did not make it to
the pan today I don't know what I'm
gonna do with that
but I'm sure we'll figure it out okay
please let this avocado still be ripe
it's questionable
she's been hanging around these parts
for a little while I think that's still
an acceptable
edible avocado
nope
jumping the gun here on this
Bagel all right slicer
slice
slice slice
I don't know what kind of fruit Bella
likes
um but I did want to bump up the fiber
here so we've got a nice selection of
things that
things that I meal prepped on the
weekend okay this is the right level of
toasting correct me if I'm wrong but
that is a beaut
okay beautiful
egg uh how do we want to do this because
the order is everything I do
that always in a way
all right let's get the avocado down
first because it's going to act as like
the glue that's what I'm working with
here
so basically you're going to pretend
like you're making avocado toast
a little smear
like that skin on there which we want to
discard all right now in my opinion
avocado is terrible without salt so
we're going to just put a little salt on
top before we even get into the egg
action this is going down nice oh she's
big
but you can't even see the bagels no one
would know no one would know this oh the
blood is supposed to go down next
guys let me screwed this up
it's okay
it's breakfast doesn't need to be
an Instagram perfect masterpiece
because Lord knows I would just like eat
the components rather than actually like
make anything with them in real life
okay that's looking pretty damn good
is it going to be an absolute disaster
to consume yes
yes it is
but
you know we're gonna work with it I need
a bib
I'm gonna wear my kids bid
shouldn't wear a dry clean only shirt
I'm gonna take a tip out of my toddler's
book
that right on there
all right
I actually need to double up sometimes
we need to double up in my house
today is one of those times
cutting off the circulation
um
she's holding together real good
um Bella I approve do you approve
we like
great success awesome it's like got
wings
[Laughter]
oh my God superhero sandwich all right
let's talk about my favorite part of the
day coffee now full disclosure I've
already had one cup of coffee this
morning because I was up at four and my
kids were ready to party at five but
Bella likely is able to like enjoy her
mornings to herself so apparently her
deal is that she has three espressos
before noon so three espressos might
seem like a lot but each shot actually
only has around 75 milligrams of
caffeine so three shots is just
equivalent to about two cups of drip
coffee which is within the recommended
guidelines cutting off your coffee by
noon is typically best practice since
caffeine has a half-life of around three
to five hours meaning it can take your
body up to three and a half hours to
eliminate half of the caffeine from your
system so in other words it would take
about twice as long to fully clear it
obviously some people can drink espresso
at 11 PM and then go to bed the next
moment no problem so how early you need
to cut off caffeine is highly
individualized and will depend on your
tolerance and your unique caffeine
metabolism capacity some of us folks
produce less of the
cyp182 enzyme or have a genetic
variation of the
adora2a gene which makes us slow
metabolizers of caffeine so we therefore
need more time but we also know that
consuming caffeine too close to bedtime
can delay the onset of sleep and reduce
Total Sleep time with one study
suggesting that caffeine six hours
before bedtime reduced sleep by a whole
hour Ah that's a no for me dog that hour
in bed is pretty precious to us
Insomniac moms I also have the slow
metabolizer genes so I have like a
strict 10 AM cut off when it comes to
caffeine just because I go to bed at
eight hashtag grandma and that's just
kind of what works for me also I I
cannot drink espresso just like straight
up in the morning so I already fixed
myself
a little soy milk latte
all caffeine is good caffeine
all right let's talk mid-morning snack
so Bella has been photographed
constantly with a green juice in her
hand basically like most of the la elite
I suppose
um so I'm just gonna like call that her
mid-morning snack listen I know I poke
fun at green juice a lot but there's
nothing inherently wrong with it if it's
something that you enjoy it really comes
down to intention are you drinking the
green juice because it's a flavorful way
to get your hydration carbohydrates and
micronutrients or are you attempting to
detox or cleanse your body FYI a lot of
influencers will insist that juicing
helps to like reset your gut by giving
your digestive system a break and while
it is true that the act of pressing
water at a produce kind of like
pre-digests it making it faster to
digest that's not necessarily a good
thing it means missing out on beneficial
5 fibers which keep us Fuller longer and
actually helps promote long-term gut
health not to mention a lot of green
juices like celery juice are rich in
fodmaps which can actually exacerbate
digestive distress so it's certainly not
for everyone yeah I don't love verdant
water and I prefer to eat my vegetables
whenever possible so I'm going to do
like a quick little snack of some
veggies and some hummus for dipping just
for some extra protein fiber and
satisfying fat
no I'm just with you you can cut it like
a normal human
good good
it's a little veggie
some snap peas
some carrots which are my fave
and
hummus
only satisfying and I'm gonna double dip
because it's my snack all right let's
move on to lunch so I was personally way
more excited to try her Tick Tock famous
prosciutto and pine nut pasta love me a
good Pasta lunch and a substantial lunch
may be particularly helpful for someone
like Bella who's been quoted as saying
she has low blood sugar and therefore
needs to eat all the time now I'm not
sure if she's referring to legitimate
hypoglycemia or she's using the phrase
casually to denote having high nutrient
needs either way I think it's a good
enough reason to reject her chiropractor
nutritionist advice to go lower carb to
keep her lean my Approach would be to
focus on having regular meals and snacks
packed with fiber rich carbs protein and
healthy fats to keep those energy levels
nice and stable
all right
okay so I found this kind of pseudo
recipe for this online
um I'm not sure where this publication
found it but I'm gonna try to follow it
kind of as best as I can we'll also Abby
find it obviously just to make it a
little bit more satiating and balanced
so it calls for a shallot I don't know
shallot so an onion is gonna have to do
the trick we got some water slowly
coming to a boil
that's how I feel about watching water
boil
you see that
chop this up quick
you're gonna cry yep are you gonna cry
oh you're gonna cry are you gonna cry
huh You're Gonna cry I'm gonna cry
huh you're gonna squirt something I'm
gonna cry my girlfriend has to cut them
every time that's so funny I never I've
never cried from it
I think I think it's a genetic thing
I don't know like I genuinely go lay
down oh my God
okay so onion we good
garlic
oh there's nothing I hate more
than having to peel garlic
tedious I'm not gonna lie I often buy
like pureed garlic because I just can't
bring myself to have to like do this
every single time and then it stinks up
your board it stinks up your hands I
just for most recipes I can't but for
you Bella for you I'm gonna be one
smelly
so she just says or whoever wrote this
recipe just says to thinly slice these
so that's we're gonna do here quick
little
I hate when they're so tight
thinking about it too
said no guy ever
yeah we know this is like hey or
whatever you would identified exactly
said no one ever suddenly it's not safe
for work
okay I feel like this is probably enough
garlic it's enough garlic for me okay
let's get some olive oil in here
this is a very poorly written recipe
I'll tell I can say okay I got it first
they want the nuts down
I normally would not toast nuts and oil
but that's what it's telling me to do so
here we are
you might as well start cutting up some
of these other guys
and cleaning up
my mother taught me you should always
clean as you go so you don't end up with
a massive mess at the end and having to
eat cold food while you clean that is
never a good time so this recipe calls
for a couple ounces of prosciutto which
is one of my favorite food groups so I'm
not going to skimp on that just a whole
food group Italian cured meats
I'm just gonna quick chop shipping out
as we call it
but the worst chef and I had ever made
now it's just butchering now it's just
just mangled okay that'll do we're gonna
pan fry that so it's gonna get crispy
and release all that delicious Porky
fat I'm gonna be using some chickpea
pasta uh just a little bit extra fiber
and protein in here and my kids really
love it too so we're gonna wait for that
to come to a rolling boil and then pop
this bad boy in and then we can get
sauteing up
those onions
oh it smells good onion and garlic down
but you know what we're gonna let them
live
we're gonna love let him enjoy his
day in the onion pool
and look at that right on cue
she is rolling
bye-bye
might be spiciest but it's gonna be a
lot call for half a teaspoon so I'm just
gonna say that's
appropriate hey let's let some of those
that hammy flavor come out
all right so while that's cooking away
I'm gonna just slice the broccolini up
take some of the rough stems off and get
them nice and thin so they cook quickly
right
Bella
Bella you [ __ ] know girl you know
I can see why this became like a like a
viral Tick Tock recipe
okay I'm gonna add a little more olive
oil so I can add in my broccolini bye
bye
all right let's just let them chill in
there for a second leave it alone say
crisp up
and what am I gonna do oh I know okay so
let's just talk about this for a second
the OG recipe is basically just calling
for the prosciutto the pasta the pine
nuts
and I mean all good things right I
figured I'm gonna build this into a more
satiating meal I've got the chickpea
pasta in there for some extra protein
and fiber I've got some broccolini here
put some extra micronutrients and color
and extra fiber I'm also going to add in
some of these turkey sausages that I
cooked up earlier just to add some extra
protein as well but I mean it is looking
like a delicious meal these are like a
roasted red pepper turkey sausages I'm
gonna add a splash of the starchy
cooking like good
just to steam these guys a little bit
that means we need
okay so last
touches here a little bit of pasta water
just to judge up that sauce lots of
Parmesan cheese
ow [ __ ]
oh no
all fixed
thanks to my Frozen my Frozen Band-Aid
[Music]
oh God it's already coming off this is
not the most food safe situation but
it's just for me so we're good this is
why people buy pre-grated cheese it's a
[ __ ] Hazard a little bit more of this
all right
all right I am very excited to play this
bad boy up all right let me clean up
okay so let's recap we got some extra
protein and fiber and the chickpea pasta
we got lots of fiber and micronutrients
in our broccolini I added some extra
protein in the turkey sausage plus we've
got healthy fats in those beautiful pine
nuts so I'm very excited to dig in I've
got to get that that prosciutto
hmm
the heat is just
perfect so good
oh all right let's talk about dinner
okay so according to Harper's Bazaar
when Bella isn't cooking for herself at
home as we just kind of did she will
usually opt for a New York slice and she
also loves the sauteed kale at a
restaurant called Westville I sadly
cannot go to New York today as much as
I'd like to but I gotta pick up the kids
from Camp so instead I have a frozen
pizza ready to go I'm just gonna Gussy
it up and I figured we can have some
sauteed kale on the side let's do it all
right so I always see these frozen
pizzas as like a blank slate something
that I can easily add whatever I have
already in the fridge on top just to
like bump up the satiety Factor so I've
got some broccoli here
and I'm just going to
mince up a little bit
so that it cooks really fast looks good
it's pretty cool sprinkle little
broccoli all right I've also got some
bell pepper which I will use some of
I never want to waste the top
tonight
a little bit of bell pepper for some
extra color
I'm making a [ __ ] mess
I need an assistant for all this
chopping dun dun dun
foreign
looks pretty good
let's pop it in the oven all right so I
got some kale here I like to just get it
really
fine and I've taken the stalks out so
that it's not like chewing on
a rubber band
got the garlic guys
I'm just going to stick it in the corner
here in some oil and hope that it's
gets nice and fragrant leave some room
there you go
does anyone else feel like really
cheated when they're sauteing greens
it's like it starts with a mound and
then you're left with like one tiny bite
add some salts
pepper
I just had an idea how do we feel about
everything bagel kale we're gonna go for
it you're gonna go for it like how is it
gonna taste bad
all right give that a quick second here
mmm it's very good
it's very good and I don't normally like
kale that much but I need that it's not
turning on me
fire alarm today all right let's just
let these guys Wilt down for a second
all right now we wait for our pizza this
looks so [ __ ]
good all right folks let's recap so we
got lots of fiber in our kale I've also
added some olive oil in there for good
measure put some extra protein on my
pizza as well as some extra veggies so
we've got some fat fiber protein all the
good stuff in life and we got pizza and
we got everything bagel spice like guys
did I nail this or what let's see
um
delicious
[Music]
whoa what was that first time eating
first I'm eating
I've never experienced
that before all right pizza time baby
Pizza Time
it's not New York but it's pretty good
honestly I was pretty impressed by this
day I mean aside from the excessive
exercise situation I feel like it was a
pretty chill food day we had pasta we
had pizza and I also had a decent amount
of veg so I'm feeling pretty good so
this is how Bella regularly eats I mean
kudos to her for rejecting the
generational diet cycle and just eating
the damn carbs and that's all that I
have for you guys today if you liked it
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below with your thoughts
and who you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]